which is how is the British context
different for the
person of faith and I know that people
when when people heard that you were
doing between this project on afternoon
on this there was a surprise but all of
a sudden Tony later maybe faith but you
said you know originally you know I've
always been a foot but it was sort of
there was some element that many were
chose your timing wisely just curious
with that experience this little vixen
Bobby but he seems a saintly person I I
mean it we see it was difficult I mean
for actually did what Tony said says
chimed with me there is a there is a
sense in which people can use God in in
in a political debate that really if you
actually are somewhat of faith really
makes you uncomfortable and also the
British are a bit reserved about these
things frankly so he has remember the
end of one speech I wanted this end the
speech by saying god bless Britain you
know and the guy tell you that was you
can't possibly say that promise for this
or that or why not one of them said
o4goodnessake runs this is an America
you know so there's always there's
there's a I think there's a natural
reserve that there is about it but I
actually I mean I didn't hide the but I
mean I used to go to church every week
and was often photographed there but I
actually had a reluctance to talk about
about God but Amina I think for me very
much you know the global poverty issue
particularly was very much linked with
my religious religious belief and faith
but it's difficult because the trouble
is you know the problem is it in in in
politics this is true instantly in the
debate about globalization and it's it's
where sometimes the risen in page
shins from political people with
religious people because actually the
decisions can be difficult you know and
sometimes religious people can be on the
side of if you only cared more than it
would be a lot easier and you know if
you're a political leader and you're in
the situation taking decisions you're
saying I yeah I care but I mean it's
this way or that way so which way do I
go and you know it can be very so I
think that is also part of the discourse
that's important and I think one of the
things that I think actually faith can
challenge political leadership but also
an engagement between faith and
political leadership also allows that to
be a bit of a two-way process so for
example in globalization I found the
hardest thing actually with the church
groups on the debt cancellation and the
g8 agenda in 2005 which is a broad
agenda not just about aid and debt but
also about governance you know I would
say to them I'm sorry we're putting
governance on the table can some of
these countries are corrupt and that's
their problem it's not because I'm not
giving them enough money the money that
is being given ends up in some place in
Switzerland so that's not right or
alternatively and more difficult in a
way you would have a fierce debate about
free trade because there were elements
within the the global poverty movement
and said free trade is a snare and
delusion for the poor it's actually
increases poverty and I would say well
hang on a minute that is a technical and
political and economic question we've
got a debate that you know i'm not
prepared justice to kind of accept that
because you're a religious person you
can say that to be and I've got to
accept that is the morally right
position so I think you know there's
that as well that interacts with all
this but I I grew Tony in the sense that
I think that i think would be really
tragic if if the faith park got squeezed
out of public life in the sense that
people actually felt embarrassed about
their that their faith and also it would
end up actually being quite dishonest
because in fact you know there are a lot
of people in the world of politics and
amazing numbers of them actually in
senior political positions who do
believe very strongly doesn't always
make them better political leaders
but its input Bob that was human being
my name is those that use fate in sort
of pandering way are the ones that are
so making it divisive and make
non-religious people for impatient as
you say I think I think this issue is
actually something we should talk about
more broadly this course because it's
really important for getting the sort of
non-religious people in bed with those
of nathan's like environmental groups on
the left that are there or not with
interest groups really working with war
and people like that you know how do you
get there more broadly is really
interesting question reporting